I'm just looking right at your belly
that's my eyes are up here Conan yeah
[Laughter]
this brings to mind you are wearing a
shirt from Japan yes I went to Japan and
I love bad English translations and this
shirt says C and D are just good sizes
this tits size fits my hand perfectly it
works in every language same thinks
twice and it's true you know if you were
when you were in Japan did you do a sort
of touristy things no I went right to
the Japanese snow monkey mountains I
don't know what that adds chill in the
hot springs the monkeys come down they
pick lice out of your hair it's great
it's very relaxing but the only thing is
the hot springs double as a monkey
toilet is this a real thing yes they
come down and they diarrhea 360 around
it's very relaxed like a mud bath yeah
it's like a mud bath so I now I have
hepatitis Grose's laughs and you're
gonna take them to the exchange in
exchange
well you posted sense well thankfully
censored photos of yourself yeah so the
uncensored version was on Instagram for
18 hours I'm very proud of that I did
scare the monkeys away and if you find
the uncensored photo just remember it
was a very very cold outside so I didn't
bring my whole Dikembe Mutombo Oh
interesting
you couldn't do it you couldn't do it I
could not do it wasn't that a great clip
subscribe to my youtube channel for an
endless supply of me
[Laughter]